you can't imagine how many times Garrett
a day I get text emailed or dm'd about
what happens if Tick Tock gets banned my
answer is nothing and everything what I
mean by that we follow attention if Tick
Tock is banned that's above my pay grade
that's you know a U.S government
decision we then realize the next day
you're talking about hundreds of
millions of people's attention is going
to be reallocated so what happens the
next day we triple down on shorts we
triple down on Spotlight on snap we
triple down on Instagram reels we
quadruple down on Facebook reels which
we're finding a lot of winning with
right now so you know to me we focus on
today we keep an eye on tomorrow because
we want to be ready for AI at scale we
want to be ready for VR at scale we want
to be ready for AR at scale and then we
challenge for a common sense consumer
debate around yesterday